i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and jan
hi everyone my name is nian and i am
back with another fun makeup look
this one is inspired by summer pastels
color but it's pretty easy to do and it
makes a lot of impact but it doesn't
take very long so this one i was
thinking of could be good for a little
park hangout park date and i hope you
guys enjoy it
so my base is done
[Music]
and you're going to need eyeliners for
this look so i'm using my clara psyche
sketch paint palette which is
one of my favorites it's water activated
so i just put water into it and then
mix but you can use liquid liners you
could use gel liners really you can be
creative here and really what this look
is is fun lines and shapes listed no
eyeliner on the top lash line for this
look we're just going to do a line above
almost like a very nice
fresh floating crease
creases down
and then same color we're gonna do two
little circles
curl the lashes
lots of mascara
and then
a little bit of lip gloss
this is a very fresh very summery look
that i've been wearing honestly a lot
lately because it is very very visually
stunning
it's so fascinating to do so
and that's it y'all hope you enjoyed
this hope you wear it to the park hope
you wear it outside hope you wear it
living your life see you next time bye
you